Was? Es gibt Werbung?
Ich habe keine Werbung. Es könnte aber auch sein, dass man eigener Streben ist und ich deswegen keine Werbung habe.
Ich bin gerade aufgestanden. Ich habe mir gedacht, ich mache jetzt einfach mal Streben an.
Vielleicht wird es jetzt. Das haben wir letzten Sonntag ja auch schon gemacht. Vielleicht kriegen wir das ja sogar regelmäßig jetzt sonntags morgens hin.
Wir gucken jetzt ein paar Videos und ein paar Sachen an und Zeugs an. So irgendwie. Keine Ahnung. Mal gucken wie lange. Bis wir wach sind auf jeden Fall.
Das erste, was ich heute Morgen gelesen habe ist auf Heise.
Das Wissen.
Ich schreibe mal Kasachstan so.
Kasachstan.
Zumindest habe ich heute Morgen gelesen.
Das war das war vielleicht war das gar nicht auf Heise. Vielleicht war es auf Polem.
Zumindest haben sie sich in Kasachstan überlegt. Ja hier acht Golem war das.
Zumindest haben sie sich in Kasachstan überlegt.
Dass jetzt alle Internet Benutzer in Kasachstan müssen sich ein SSL Zertifikat installieren von der wahrscheinlich von der Internet Überwachungs Behörde oder wie auch immer das bei denen heißt.
Ziemlich beknackt ist. Ich bin gerade aufgestanden.
Und wenn man wenn man auf eine Seite geht die verschlüsselt ist und man hat das Zertifikat nicht installiert hinterlegt bei sich.
Dann wird man umgeleitet vom Provider auf eine Webseite wo darstellt dass man das Zertifikat installieren muss.
Das ist mein Big Brain hier.
Ich frage mich wann sie bei uns auch so Ideen kommen.
So Sachen werden ja immer mehr salonfähig.
Dann mache ich halt SSH Tunnel über. Keine Ahnung Uzbekistan oder keine.
SSH Tunnel über Indonesisches VPN oder irgendwie sowas.
Was zockst du eigentlich auf Konsole oder PC hauptsächlich PC.
Wobei es in letzter Zeit wenig Games gibt die mir gefallen.
Das spiele ich recht wenig.
Ich habe letztens sogar mal wieder Half Life 2 installiert.
Einfach so als ich wusste was ich spielen soll.
Hast du jemals die Homepage von Stack Overflow gesehen.
Ach so du meinst die Startseite.
Das ist eine gute Frage.
Die Homepage habe ich glaube ich nie gesehen.
Factorio kenne ich. Factorio habe ich schon eine ganze Weile gespielt.
Allerdings gibt es bestimmt mittlerweile schon jede Menge Updates dazu.
Die ich noch nicht gespielt habe. Factorio ist ein Eis.
Ja aber das ist schon hart hier.
Muss Zertifikat einspielen dass die Regierung man in den Mitteln kann.
Ich habe gelesen dass irgendwer erzählt dass Fliegen unbedingt teurer werden muss.
Das haben wir letztens auch in den News.
Und da ist mir mal wieder aufgefallen dass ich keine Ahnung habe.
Also bei so geilen Aussagen immer.
Dass ich keine Ahnung habe wen ich wählen soll.
Es ist ja noch ein bisschen hinten. Ich weiß es echt nicht.
Es gibt für mich einfach keinen den ich irgendwie richtig wählen kann.
Es gibt irgendwie immer nur Aussagen die so schwarz und weiß sind.
Naja zumindest ist vielleicht schon mal irgendjemand auf die Idee gekommen.
Dass man nicht Fliegen unbedingt teurer machen muss.
Sondern man könnte ja auch dafür sorgen dass es ordentliche Alternativen gibt.
Dass die Leute nicht mehr fliegen müssen.
Ich meine ich finde es bescheuert dass so viele Leute fliegen.
Beziehungsweise dass so viel Umweltverschmutzung passiert was Flugzeuge und vor allem auch Schiffe angeht.
Wenn ich mir überlege ich bestelle ja selbst von Aliexpress was das kostet.
Also was das an Zeug ausstößt ist ja auch nicht feierlich.
Aber warum sagt man nicht einfach.
Das ist eh was was ich vermisse irgendwie.
Es wurde so ein Plan dahinter wie das gemacht werden soll.
Also die Noob Variante ist wenn man feststellt die Leute fahren zu viel mit dem Auto.
Und die Leute fliegen zu viel mit dem Flugzeug.
Die Noob Variante ist dann zu sagen ahja gut dann müssen wir halt verbieten mit dem Auto zu fahren.
Und das Fliegen so teuer machen da es keiner mehr fliegen kann.
Das ist die Noob Variante die eigentlich viel sinnvollere Variante.
Die Leute müssen sich ja irgendwie von A nach B bewegen können.
Die eigentlich sinnvolle Variante wäre ja man versucht irgendwie Alternativen zu schaffen.
So mit einem Plan dahinter.
Ich weiß Plan ist nicht so beliebt irgendwie.
Aber mit einem Plan dahinter dass man sagt okay wir haben uns jetzt vorgestellt Nahverkehr für die nächsten 15 Jahre einen Plan.
Und nicht nur einen Plan wo es heißt in 15 Jahren wollen wir das und das machen.
Sondern oder sagen wir 20 Jahren.
Sondern einen Plan wo man sagen kann okay die nächsten zwei Jahre passiert das.
Die nächsten zwei Jahre passiert das.
Dass man auch zwischendurch nachguckt wie das denn aussieht.
Nicht wie unsere Internetausbaupläne die wir immer haben.
So nach dem Motto bis 2020 das und das für alle.
Und dann ist es Mitte 2020 und dann kommt dann oh Mist.
Das haben wir gar nicht geschafft.
Damit konnte keiner rechnen dass wir das nicht schaffen.
Wir haben bisher alle unsere Breitbandziele erreicht.
Wie konnte man darauf kommen dass wir es nicht schaffen bis 2000 das kann überhaupt nicht sein.
Du bräuchtest einen ordentlichen Plan wie das gemacht werden soll.
Auch einen Plan wo man die Umsetzung irgendwie nachvollziehen kann.
Ein Plan der öffentlich ist.
Wo man irgendwie erkennt okay da hat sich einer Gedanken gemacht.
Und das ist was womit ich irgendwie letztendlich leben kann.
Ich finde es vollkommen okay und auch notwendig dass man das alles ein bisschen einschränkt.
Allerdings am besten ist das natürlich wenn man dann auch Alternativen bietet die die Leute verwenden können.
Was hat es für einen Sinn wenn du sagst wir verbieten das.
Wir machen das andere teurer aber wir haben keine Alternativen.
Ja was bleibt den Leuten denn anders übrig.
Also meiner Ansicht nach müsste das Ziel sein dass du innerhalb von Deutschland dich zumindest ohne Probleme.
Von einer Stadt zur anderen Stadt bewegen kannst mit öffentlichen Verkehrsmitteln.
Und halt auch in angemessenem Zeitrahmen.
Also sprich dass ich beispielsweise von Frankfurt nach Köln ist jetzt ein doofes Beispiel.
Weil Frankfurt Köln ist ziemlich easy.
Dass jetzt vielleicht schon ein bisschen kleineren Stadt drum herum.
Keine Ahnung alle 10 Minuten nach Frankfurt komme.
Wenn ich dann in Frankfurt am Südbahnhof bin.
Dass ich dann weiter fahren kann mit irgendwas anderem.
In Frankfurt selbst ist ja kein Problem.
Aber das müsste halt vielmehr ausgebaut sein.
Aktuell ist es so da hast du Strecken die willst du fahren.
Da fahren zwei Züge am Tag oder lass mal fünf Züge am Tag sein.
Oder teilweise Züge mit zwei Stunden Unterschied.
Es ist voll für Arsch.
Wie kann man ernsthaft den Leuten erzählen die da wohnen nach dem Auto.
Ja ne ihr dürft mit dem Auto nicht mehr nach Frankfurt fahren.
Das ist doch total hängen geblieben.
Vor allem überzeugst du letztendlich ja auch keinen mit solchen Sachen.
Die Leute überzeugst du damit nicht mit du verbietest alles.
Das kann man machen.
Das kann man machen wenn es Alternativen gibt.
Du überzeugst ja die Leute nicht damit wenn du die ganzen Sachen irgendwie verbietest.
Oder noch besser den Leuten sagst ich will noch drüber reden ist auch ganz böse.
Sondern indem du irgendwelche Alternativen zumindest in Aussicht stellst.
Wo die Leute dann sagen können okay das ist gut damit kann ich leben.
Da brauch ich das andere ja gar nicht mehr.
Ja und sowas.
Also es ist irgendwie ich vermisse generell bei vielen Sachen so den Plan dahinter einfach.
Ich glaube es ist unstrittig dass wir Maßnahmen zum Umweltschutz brauchen.
Also irgendwie außer irgendwelche tollen Aussagen so hier das müssen wir jetzt sofort abschalten.
Das müssen wir machen.
So ein Plan dahinter irgendwie oder auch was Breitbandausbau Internet angeht.
Oder was Infrastrukturausbau Nahverkehr Bahn angeht.
Irgendwie vermisse ich so den langfristigen Plan dahinter einfach.
Und wie gesagt kein Plan der irgendwie sagt in 30 Jahren wollen wir das haben.
Weil who cares was in 30 Jahren ist das sagt man dann einfach so.
Nein das muss ein Plan sein wo drinnen steht ganz genau wie es ablaufen soll.
Dass man auch kontrollieren kann wie es aussieht.
Aber das kriegen sie.
Das funktioniert irgendwie nicht.
Und heute machen wir es so.
Heute ist alles mehr oder weniger schwarz und weiß.
Wenn du was sagst was quasi gerade nicht so offensichtlicher Konsens ist oder vorgeschriebener Konsens.
Da wirst du quasi fast gesellschaftlich fast schon halb gesteinig.
Wie kann man das denn sagen?
Das geht ja gar nicht.
Und ich glaube nicht dass es förderlich ist wenn man Diskussionen über Sachen die die Leute bewegt unterbindet.
Anstatt darüber zu diskutieren.
Das hat auch noch nie irgendwie funktioniert.
Und übrigens Leute ich habe gestern Apollo 11 im Kino geguckt.
Das ist also kein Film das ist eine Dokumentation mit.
Also ich würde mal sagen zu 95% manche Sachen waren glaube ich nicht.
Original Filmaufnahmen aber zu 95% aus also das da.
Was hier?
Dokumentation das ist eineinhalb Stunden eine Stunde 33 oder so steht glaube ich drauf Laufzeit.
Und wir sind ein paar Sachen aufgefallen als ich das gesehen habe.
Erstens habe ich ja gestern schon auf Twitter geschrieben.
Dass die Astronauten in der Rakete beim Start einen niedrigeren Puls hatten als ich wenn ich auf dem Klo sitze.
Also ein 88er Puls.
Ja also unter mir explodieren gerade irgendwie zig Tonnen von Flüssigtreibstoff was auch immer.
Keine Ahnung was sich das zusammensetzt.
Unter mir explodieren gerade tonnenweise irgendwelche Sachen aber Puls von 88.
Easy überhaupt kein Problem.
Okay also wahrscheinlich habe ich einen höheren Puls wenn ich auf dem Klo sitze.
Als der Typ wenn er in der Rakete sitzt so die Rakete startet gerade.
Ja wieso spoilerst du das?
Ja Scheiße ne?
Spoiler meiner Sache die 50 Jahre her ist.
Zumindest das ist so die Sache wo ich mir gedacht habe das war schon nicht schlecht.
Aber was mir dabei auch noch aufgefallen ist.
Und übrigens ich kann es jedem empfehlen sich anzugucken.
Es ist halt kein Film in dem Sinne.
Es ist halt wirklich eine Doku aber die ist ziemlich gut geschnitten.
Und hat auch kaum Längen was du bei anderen Dokus oftmals hast.
Ja es geht eigentlich Schlag auf Schlag.
Und im Prinzip hast du auch kaum Erzähler in dem Sinne du hast eigentlich nur Funkverkehr.
Und ein bisschen drumherum Gerede von dem Missions Commander Typ.
Was übrigens ganz schrecklich war waren die Untertitel.
Also ich hätte jedes mal ausflippen können.
Der Film ist im Original Ton ja allerdings mit riesengroßen Untertiteln was übelst der Fail ist.
Und wenn sie dann Engine mit Maschine übersetzen habe ich schon immer.
Die haben nicht irgendwie gesagt die haben teilweise gesagt Engine ist Maschine.
Und ich meine ernsthaft das ist eine Rakete.
Seit wann ist eine Engine bei einer Rakete eine Maschine?
Also wer übersetzt das denn mit Maschine?
Wer hat das übersetzt?
Das ist ein Triebwerk in dem Fall aber keine Maschine.
Egal aber die Untertitel waren teilweise echt grausam.
Aber der Film ist zum Glück im Original Ton.
Es wirkte wirklich ein bisschen wie Google Translate.
Also da weiß ich auch nicht was.
Zumindest kann man auf jeden Fall empfehlen man muss es auch nicht im Kino gucken.
Ich meine es wirkt schon cool.
Und was mir aufgefallen ist noch.
Erstens wie gut die Filmaufnahmen ausgesehen haben.
Ich meine das ist 50 Jahre her wo sie den Kram aufgenommen haben.
Und die Filmaufnahmen sahen richtig gut aus.
Sogar die Filmaufnahmen aus diesem komischen Landemodul sahen halbwegs gut aus.
Die hatten eine Kamera dabei mit einem FPS.
Aber von der Auflösung her war das echt nice.
Das könnte glatt als 1080p Video durchgehen wenn du das heute dir anguckst.
Ein FPS Kamera.
Harnihoch Studio Kameras.
Da war ich echt überrascht wie gut die Filmaufnahmen ausgesehen haben.
Natürlich nicht von allem.
Wenn du da eine Kamera an einem Triebwerk hängen hattest.
Das hat schon ganz schön gewackelt und sah nicht gut aus.
Das waren immer die originalen Aufnahmen.
Und was mich auch echt überrascht hat ist.
Wie gut die Audioaufnahmen waren.
Ich meine man muss sich mal überlegen.
Wie weit ist der Mond weg von der Erde.
300.000 Kilometer oder so.
Ja 400.000 Kilometer.
So und die Audioaufnahmen.
Die klangen teilweise besser als aktuelle VoIP Gespräche.
Wir haben auf der Arbeit ja das große Vergnügen mit SkyforBusiness arbeiten zu dürfen.
Und wir haben auch so ein paar Microsoft Surface Hubs.
Das sind so große Fernsehdinger mit einem riesen Touchscreen.
Die sind übelst teuer.
Gucken wir was so ein Ding heißt.
30K oder so was.
Ähm.
Ne ne ne.
Kann man so irgendwie gar nicht kaufen.
Das sind irgendwie so 70 Zoll Bildschirme mit Touchscreen.
Das ist übelst nice eigentlich.
Zumindest was man machen kann.
Man kann über Skype dann eine Telefonkonferenz oder eine Audiokonferenz einladen.
Und was ganz besonders abartig ist.
Wenn du externe Leute, die nicht im gleichen SkyforBusiness sind.
Einlädst dazu.
Das läuft dann folgendermaßen.
Die kriegen per Mail eine Nachricht.
Dass sie jetzt eingeladen sind zu einer SkyforBusiness Konferenz.
Und da drinnen ist ein Link.
Den klickst du an.
Und dann kriegst du einen Secret Code.
Mit diesem Secret Code musst du dann per Telefon bei so einem Telefondienst anrufen.
Gibst den Secret Code.
Die kommt den Konferenzcode ein.
Und dann wirst du quasi über diesen Anbieter in die Konferenz zugeschaltet.
So der Witz ist natürlich, dass der externe Anbieter, der dann anrufen bei uns intern an der Telefonkonferenz teilnehmen will.
Selbst ja auch irgendein komisches VoIP-System hat.
Leute ich sag euch.
Die Qualität von diesen Gesprächen ist um ein Vielfaches schlechter.
Als die Kommunikation mit Apollo 11 400.000 km entfernt.
Apollo 11 hast du wenigstens alles verstanden, was die Leute gesagt haben, wenn man sich Mühe gegeben hat.
War der Skype-Konferenz über drei VoIP-Systeme drüber.
Über zigmal Format gewandelt.
Kompression.
Dann irgendwie noch digital analog, analog digital.
Was auch immer alles umgewandelt zwischendurch.
Die Qualität ist heute bei so einer Telefonkonferenz, obwohl die alle in Frankfurt sitzen, schlechter.
Als die mit den Leuten auf dem Mond telefoniert haben.
Kommuniziert haben.
Voller Witz eigentlich.
Naja und was mir noch aufgefallen ist dabei.
Als ich das geguckt habe.
Sag mal so.
Vor allem in Europa.
Bestehen wir ja gerade so ein bisschen vor der Herausforderung, wie wir Leute integrieren.
In Deutschland natürlich.
Auch in Schweden ist es ja wohl aktuell ganz besonders schlimm.
Und eine Sache ist mir dabei aufgefallen.
Dass es eigentlich überhaupt nicht darum geht.
Oder zumindest glaube ich das.
Also zumindest kommt mir das irgendwie schlüssig vor, nachdem ich das geguckt habe.
Dass es gar nicht so sehr darum geht, den Leuten irgendwas aufzuzwingen.
Also in beide Richtungen.
Nach dem Motto, du musst dich jetzt hier anpassen und du musst besonders tolerant sein und du musst das und du musst dich hier einschränken.
Und das kannst du nicht sagen.
Sondern ich glaube, das was wirklich die Leute vereint.
Oder was wirklich die Leute vereinen kann.
Ist, wenn sie gemeinsame Ziele haben.
Und dann ist es doch im Prinzip scheißegal.
Für was der persönliche Antrieb eines jeden ist, der da mitmacht, warum er das macht.
Das gemeinsame Ziel haben sie trotzdem alle.
Also nachdem ich das geguckt habe, glaube ich echt.
Man vereint Leute nicht damit, dass man es ihnen aufzwängt.
Sondern dass man es schafft, dass quasi die unterschiedlichsten Leute ein gemeinsames Ziel und, nennen wir es mal, gemeinsame Visionen haben.
Und wenn man das hinkriegt, dann ziehen auch ganz viele Leute an einem Strang.
Ich glaube, das haben wir noch nicht geschafft.
Gut, ich meine, wir können jetzt nicht sagen, alle Leute, wir bauen jetzt alle eine Rakete zusammen.
Aber so vom Ansatz her, wisst ihr was ich meine?
Und was ich auch verstehen kann ist, warum, wenn man das geguckt hat, warum man damals gedacht hat, dass wir quasi 2019 mal mindestens irgendwie auf dem Mars oder sonst wo rumhüpfen.
Und heute machen wir Skype for Business VoIP Calls.
Patrick, es sind nicht nur Einser, es sind auch Urls.
Weiß nicht, weil es ist halt so, es ist gleich wie mit Eins.
Und was auch richtig cool zu sehen war, wenn man sich den Film angeguckt hat, dass an ganz vielen Stellen im Kommunikations-Dings da Center und überall, dass überall auch Frauen dabei gewesen sind.
Weil heute teilweise so getan wird, als sind in solchen Berufen, als gibt es da quasi überhaupt keine Frauen oder so.
Ey, es gab damals Frauen und ich bin mir sicher, die haben genauso dazu beigetragen, dass das funktioniert hat.
Das sollte man ja nicht unter den Teppich kehren.
Und das hat damals sogar ganz ohne Feminismus und alle Männer sind scheiße funktioniert.
Sachen gibt's, äh.
Kurz eine Frage, du sagst Windows VM in der KVM am besten in der Grafikkarte am Haus, damit das ordentlich läuft, was?
Was? Nein, sag ich nicht.
Also evtl. wenn man das gesehen hat, wird man sehen, dass so ziemlich nichts an dieser ganzen Mission von einer Person gemacht wurde.
Das waren hunderte Leute dran in allen möglichen Sachen.
Und du hast auch gesehen, da war keiner irgendwie mit halber Arschbacke dabei.
Die haben sich alle halb in die Hose geschissen, wenn sie mal 15 Sekunden lang nichts gehört haben.
Aber noch mal zu dem, was Sharks Development geschrieben hat, wie kommst du darauf?
Du sagst Windows VM in der KVM am besten in der Grafikkarte vom Haus.
Hä? Nee, warum?
Einfach Windows...
Moment, warte mal.
Nee. Also in KVM laufen Windows VMs auch ohne Probleme.
Also überhaupt kein Ding.
Überhaupt kein Ding.
Und wenn du eine Grafikkarte durchreichst an die VM, wird's sogar komplizierter,
weil du dann einen extra Monitor brauchst an der Ausgang von der Grafikkarte.
Also für dich wird keine extra Grafikkarte durchreichen.
Also wenn ich Windows unter Linux verwenden müsste, würde ich mir überlegen, ob ich nicht...
Also wenn es zu Desktop-Zwecken ist, ob ich nicht einfach VirtualBox nehme, weil damit funktioniert das wahrscheinlich besser.
Ähm...
Und ansonsten einfach KVM-Windows installieren, Tools installieren.
Aber rein auf dem Desktop Windows-Virtualisierung unter Linux würde ich sagen,
ist tatsächlich VirtualBox sogar noch ein Ticken besser.
Ja, so und jetzt machen wir das, was wir das letzte Mal auch gemacht haben,
nachdem ich mich jetzt sehr ewig daran ausgelassen hab.
Ähm...
Zu irgendwelchen gesellschaftlichen Problemen, die wir haben.
Gibt's da irgendwelche Fragen, die ich übersehen hab?
Gucken.
Äh, Timbo sagt, was ich grad finde, dass die mit Taschenrechnerleistung losgeflogen sind.
Jaja, die sind vor allem, die sind nicht nur mit Taschenrechnerleistung losgeflogen,
die sind auch teilweise einfach mal manuell losgeflogen.
Die hatten auf dem Fenster aufgemalt so nen, so nen...
Das sah aus ein bisschen wie Millimeterpapier.
Und danach sind die, sind die Sachen angeflogen.
Nach, nach quasi aufgemalten Einheiten auf dem Fenster.
Ah, also da mussten auch schon Leute drin sitzen, die halbwegs wissen, was sie machen,
sonst würde das nicht funktionieren.
Aber es war schon nice, sich anzugucken.
Also wie gesagt, die Doku kann ich echt empfehlen, das ist, das ist super zusammengeschnitten.
Es ist qualitativ ziemlich gut von den Aufnahmen her,
für das, dass das uralt ist eigentlich, ne, aus heutigen Gesichtspunkten.
Ja, und wenn's geht, guckt's euch ohne Untertitel an,
weil die sind eigentlich, die sind, die sind nur im Weg und die sind scheiße übersetzt.
Man braucht da, man braucht wirklich auch, selbst wenn man richtig schlecht Englisch kann,
oder gar kein Englisch kann, ähm, man braucht den Ton,
also man braucht das Commentary gar nicht großartig dabei.
Es reicht schon eigentlich, wenn man sich das anguckt.
So, und jetzt gucken wir mal, ich hab hier ne Playlist auf YouTube,
aber auf dem anderen, äh, keine Playlist auf YouTube,
eine Playlist von YouTube, also die ich zusammen gebastelt hab.
Ich hab, ich guck ja immer, wenn ich abends, wenn ich ins Bett gehe,
guck ich schon ein bisschen auf'm Tablet, ein bisschen, bisschen Videos oder Streams
oder sowas zum Einpennen und ich speichere mir einfach immer alle möglichen Videos,
die irgendwie interessant klingen und da hab ich jetzt mal ein paar rauskopiert
und wir gucken uns das Ganze an.
Übrigens, hab ich gelesen, das müssen wir uns angucken.
Habt ihr schon den Witcher 3 Trailer gesehen?
Ich hab heut morgen gelesen, es gibt ne Witcher 3 Trailer.
Ne, nicht ein Witcher 3 Trailer, vergiss es, nen Witcher Serie Trailer.
Alter Herr Big Brain, es ist noch früh.
Witcher Serie Trailer, nicht Witcher 3 Trailer.
Ja.
Witcher Trailer, so rum.
Netflix, genau.
Den wollt ich nämlich auch noch gucken.
Mit Superman, genau.
Official Teaser, zwei Minuten.
German, German Trailer.
Lass uns mal den...
Netflix, vor einem Tag, ja, das wird er sein.
Okay, Musik aus, müssen wir uns jetzt angucken.
Bin ich echt gespannt drauf.
Könnt ihr euch noch an den Shitstorm erinnern,
wo sie gesagt haben, Siri sollte ne Asiatin werden?
Die sich da alle aufgeregt haben, ey.
Und Yennefer, sollte jemand aus Indien spielen oder irgendwie sowas?
Ich weiß nicht, was da rausgekommen ist aus der ganzen Sache.
Das einzige, was ich weiß, ist, dass Superman Geralt spielt.
Da, gucken wir mal.
Das ist Siri, oder?
Milfgarde ist da.
Egal, was du wählst.
Du kommst raus, blöd.
Ich fand den Trailer nice.
Ich hab den Eindruck,
dass manche Sachen, dass manche so ein bisschen CGI-Hintergründe sind, oder?
Oder zumindest, wenn ich CGI-Hintergründe, dann zumindest...
CGI-Enhanced-Hintergründe.
Weil spätestens seit Herr der Ringe wird ja so ne Schlacht
nicht mehr mit 50.000 Leuten gemacht,
sondern halt mit, keine Ahnung, 20 oder so.
Hat irgendwie nicht viel mit Witcher, keine Ahnung, ehrlich gesagt.
Ich mein, sie haben ja gesagt, dass sich das Ganze nach den Büchern richtet
und wohl auch quasi ab dem ersten Buch anfängt.
Ich hab keine Ahnung, ich hab das nicht gelesen.
Ich kann es überhaupt nicht einschätzen, ob das was mit Witcher zu tun hat, oder nicht?
Keine Ahnung.
Also für mich sieht das hier schon sehr Witcher-Style aus.
Warum die in Fantasy-Filmen allerdings immer irgendwelche komischen Lederdinger anhaben müssen,
das verstehe ich tatsächlich nicht.
Keiner, der noch irgendwie bei Verstand ist
und vor allem keiner dagegen irgendwelche gefährlichen Monsterdinger kämpfen muss,
würde sich irgendwie hautengen Lederkram anziehen.
Wozu?
Er ist ein Hexer, da muss ich hautenges Lederzeug anziehen, schon klar.
Ähm...
Ja, ich glaube mal, dass du dich da drin gar nicht mehr gut bewegen kannst.
Vor allem biete das null Schutz gegen irgendwas.
Trifft dich das Monster einmal, bam!
Kettenrüstung stört überhaupt nicht.
Ich hatte mal bei uns...
Also, jetzt ist es ewig her.
Wer konnte mal bei uns eine Kettenrüstung anziehen, auf so einem Mittelaltermarkt?
Hattest du mal eine Kettenrüstung an? Das merkst du kaum.
Eine Kettenhemd merkst du kaum.
Das juckt überhaupt nicht.
Ich hatte mal auf so einem Mittelaltermarkt, hatte ich mal eine Kettenrüstung an
und du merkst das kaum, dass du ein Kettenhemd anhast.
Vielleicht hat er ja ein Kettenhemd drunter.
Okay, ja, kann ja sein, kann ja sein.
Ich finde es sieht schon...
Und eins muss ich sagen...
Ich finde schon, wo hat man es denn gesehen?
Irgendwo saß er doch auf dem Bett und hat irgendwie so Witcher-mäßig geguckt.
Weiß nicht wo.
Ich fand es da schon... Ich habe auch erst gedacht, okay, er sieht irgendwie immer noch aus wie Superman,
aber ich finde das trifft es doch echt ganz gut.
Also ich finde das echt nicht übel.
Er hat kein Kettenhemd drunter.
Hätte ein Kettenhemd drunter, würde man das sehen.
Das ist einfach YOLO, der YOLO-Witcher-Style.
Wer braucht schon Kettenhemd und wer braucht schon irgendwie Rüstung?
Overrated.
Ja, ich finde das sieht schon wirklich cool aus, wie sie das gemacht haben.
Ich meine, der hat auch schon ordentlich Muckis hier.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, ob Geralt in den Büchern auch so ein großkulöser Klotz ist.
Aber ich finde es sieht schon nicht schlecht aus.
Also ich fand den Trailer nicht schlecht.
Wann kommt denn das Ganze raus?
Und ganz ehrlich, die Verteilung von Likes zu Dislikes fällt eindeutig zugunsten von Netflix aus.
Weil die Hardcore-Fans so sehr, so sehr, so sehr, so sehr, so sehr, so sehr, so sehr, so sehr, so sehr, so sehr, so sehr, so sehr, so sehr, so sehr, so sehr, so sehr, so sehr.
Weil die Hardcore-Fans sowohl von Büchern als auch Spielen sind immer enttäuscht.
Du kannst es im Prinzip keinem so richtig recht machen mit einer Serien- oder Film-Umsetzung.
Das heißt, die Likes zu Dislikes, da haben auch sehr viele Hardcore-Fans geliked.
Also das für so eine bekannte Marke im Endeffekt ist dieses Like-Dislike-Verhältnis spricht eindeutig für Netflix.
Hallo? Wo sind die Comments? Ja.
Ja, aber die Trailer haben ja oftmals eine merkwürdige Musik, wo man sich denkt, das hat mit dem eigentlichen wenig zu tun.
Was mich echt enttäuscht hat, was Trailer und Musik ist, der...
Könnt ihr euch noch an den...
Könnt ihr euch noch an den Press of the Wild-Trailer erinnern?
Und zwar an diesen Part. Ich zeig nur den Part, den ich meine.
Genau, ab hier. Ab hier.
Du denkst dir, pass mal jetzt. Also ab jetzt.
Das war... Das ist einer der geilsten Trailer, die Nintendo je gemacht hat, ne?
Und wisst ihr, was das Problem ist?
Dass die Musik auch übelst geil klingt und die Musik in Press of the Wild ist im Vergleich zum Trailer...
Ich will nicht sagen totaler Crap, aber irgendwie nicht vorhanden im Vergleich zum Trailer.
Ich war übelst gehypt, als ich den Trailer gesehen habe.
Vor allem, wo die Fee aus dem See rauskommt.
Die Musik passt übelst geil.
Und wenn sie dann noch das Overworld-Main-Theme einspielt...
Das war richtig geil. Ich hab mir gesagt, endlich mal ein Orchester-Soundtrack, ein richtig geiler Zelt-Soundtrack.
Und dann kommt... Und dann kommt... Dann kommt das hier.
Es ist nicht schlecht, es passt irgendwie auch zu dem Game.
Sie haben ja gesagt... Sie haben ja gesagt, sie haben das so gemacht, weil sie wollen, dass die Welt im Vordergrund steht und sowas.
Aber ich bin der Ansicht, so gut Press of the Wild an sich war, zumindest von der Spielwelt her und von dem, was du machen konntest...
Ich bin immer noch der Ansicht, irgendwie hat dem Spiel... Hätte dem Spiel ein bisschen mehr Story nicht geschadet.
Ich mein, Press of the Wild hat im Endeffekt keine Story.
Das hat die letzten 10 Minuten ein bisschen Story, aber die ist nicht wirklich da.
Und den Teil von der Story, den man zwischendurch sieht, ist total belanglos.
Also... Ne... Ich hätt's viel cooler gefunden, es wäre mehr Musik in dem Style gewesen.
Zumindest... Ich mein, man hätte ja... Das ist einfach übelst epische Zelda-Musik.
Gut, wenn Zelda jetzt da... Dann nicht.
Aber das ist übelst nice.
Und die Trailer-Musik ist besser, als die ganze Musik im fertigen Spiel.
Also es ist übelst...
Wirechamp, äh...
Nachdem ich den Trailer geguckt hab, hab ich mir schon gedacht, du musst dir wahrscheinlich noch den Soundtrack holen, bevor du das Spiel holst.
Aber war dann halt nicht so...
Das beste Zelda-Musik ist immer noch das.
Beste... Beste Zelda-Musik.
Ach was, Song of Storms. Beste, Dark Overworld.
Das kannst du dir stundenlang, wenn du da rumgelaufen bist und nicht wusstest, wo du hin musst.
Beste.
Sieht nicht aus wie das Master-Shirt, es sieht...
Kann man mir das ausschauen, aber nicht wie das Master-Shirt.
Bestes Overworld-Theme hier.
Allerdings muss man sagen, die haben auch andere sehr geile Sachen.
Ending.
Skyward Sword war ja nicht so beliebt, ne.
Aber Skyward Sword hat einen richtig guten Soundtrack.
Stellt euch das mal in Breath of the Wild vor, das wär noch was gewesen.
Ich mein, es passt... Okay, man muss sagen, es passt zu Skyward Sword auch deutlich besser als zu Breath of the Wild.
Aber trotzdem, ich fand die Musik in Breath of the Wild jetzt...
Moment, ich werd keine Blumen Zwiebeln kaufen.
Ist ein bisschen hinter dem zurückgeblieben, was ich mir gewünscht hätte.
Es hat seine Gründe, dass sie es so gemacht haben, okay.
Aber ich hätt's mir irgendwie anders gewünscht.
Aber man kriegt halt nicht immer, was man haben will, ne.
Okay, wir wollten uns eigentlich angucken.
Das wollte ich mir eigentlich angucken.
Was haben wir vor USB benutzt?
Das hab ich heute Morgen auf dem Tablet angefangen zu gucken.
So die ersten paar Minuten hab ich mir gedacht, äh, guckst du nachher im Rechner weiter?
Breath of the Wild, Blumen Zwiebel.
Breath of the Blumen Zwiebel, ja.
Ich weiß auch nicht, warum hab ich denn hier...
Warum hab ich hier Dings drinnen?
Green Brokers, limited, Blumen Zwiebel, 6 verschiedene Frühlingsblumen besorgen.
Weil...
Okay, was haben wir vor USB benutzt?
Was fällt mir denn da ein?
Was haben wir vor USB benutzt?
Vor USB haben wir benutzt serielle Schnittstelle.
Also Serial Port, Parallel Port, Joystick Port.
Falls das noch überhaupt irgendjemand kennt.
Joystick.
Was dann oftmals irgendwie an der Soundkarte als Gaming Port oder so dran war.
PS2. PS2 haben wir noch verwendet.
Diesen Dienststecker, kennt ihr noch jemand?
Den da, den fetten.
IDE? Ja, wobei IDE anstatt USB, nee.
Ähm, es geht ja um was man anstatt USB verwendet, aber so für externe Geräte.
Kennt ihr diesen hässlichen Dienststecker noch jemand?
Das war noch, das war noch vor PS2 hatte man diese Dinger.
Und dann gab es dann so tolle Sachen wie einen PS2 auf Dienststecker Adapter.
Mr. Hard Toast. Ach du Scheiße. Nice.
Ja, wenn man noch Rechner auf der Arbeit hat mit Dienststecker, dann weiß man was man da vor sich hat.
Okay, ähm, gucken wir mal. Also was haben wir vorher benutzt?
Wir verbinden praktisch alles mit USB. Keyboards, Mice, Spiegel, Bones, sogar Mini-Konsolen sind mit USB verwendet.
Aber was haben wir vorher benutzt, bevor diese wunderschöne Verbindung in Ordnung geworden ist?
USB, also universal serial...
Bisschen lauter, okay.
Das ist ja geil. Die meisten davon gibt es nicht mehr.
RIP, RIP. Also ich weiß nicht ob es nicht nur Überreste davon gibt, aber im Endeffekt...
RIP, RIP. Gibt es noch? Gibt es noch? Gibt es noch? RIP, RIP.
Ja, genau, habe ich doch gesagt. Gut, ihr müsst dazu sagen, ich habe das Video am Anfang schon gesehen vorher.
Serial, Parallel, Joystick, PS2, genau.
Nicht IBM RIP, die anderen IBM gibt es noch.
Das war die Seite, die man früher an Drucker angeschlossen hat.
Der DIN Stecker!
Deutsches Institut für Normung!
Kassette.
Das war noch pre-floppy disk.
IBM ist doch jetzt Lenovo. Nee, nee, da sind zwei unterschiedliche Läden.
Allerdings hat IBM Notebooks und Serverhardware zum größten Teil an Lenovo verkauft.
Habt ihr es gesehen, Leute? Die sind richtig next level. Die haben einen Klinkelstecker.
Die sind weiter als wir 2019. 1975 oder 1980, wann das war.
Diese hässlichen Stecker damals.
Wieser-Snoops, ja.
Ich meine, du konntest das Zeug damals theoretisch sogar noch ablöten, wenn man sich das anguckt.
Ich meine, hat keiner so wirklich gemacht. So ein paar ganz hardcore Leute.
Und du hast sogar noch die einzelne Leiterbahn erkannt.
Heute hast du irgendwie so einen, was weiß ich, 95 Schichten PCB oder sowas.
Und bald wurde das IBM PC Compatible Markt geboren und eine Waschung mit Maschinen.
Oh Gott, das Zeug.
5,25 Zolles Kette.
Wie oft habt ihr fast den Port rausgerissen, weil ihr an diesem Kabel hängen geblieben seid?
Na gut, wahrscheinlich nicht so viele, weil wahrscheinlich nicht so viele den Kram hatten.
Aber die Stecker, ich hab die nie angeschraubt.
Ich hab die nie angeschraubt, weil ich sonst immer halb den Port rausgerissen hab, wenn ich hängen geblieben bin.
Adapter auf Adapter auf Adapter, ja?
Das war damals fast normal, dass du für manche Sachen so einen dicken Adapter an Adapter-Ding hattest.
Wie haben die das früher ohne RGB gemacht?
Tari 2600 oder Sega Megadrive zum Beispiel.
Ja, wohl.
Guckt euch mal die Werbung an. Guckt euch mal die Werbung an.
Warum liegt die dahinter?
Warum liegt die dahinter und guckt so? Warum?
Alter, heute werden die Feministen ausrasten bei so einer Werbung.
Vor allem, die liegt voll auf der Kante, du siehst richtig, die die kurz vor dem runterfallen.
Das sind Pedale, ja.
Ey, das war damals. Moment. Also gestern haben wir mal gelernt. Sekunde.
Gestern haben wir ja gelernt, wer im Stream gestern dabei war.
Die richtige Einheit ist It's pro Sekunde und nicht etwa Bits pro Sekunde.
Die Chinesen wussten das schon immer. Es ist It's pro Sekunde.
115k It's pro Sekunde war damals echt viel.
Da hat man sogar noch Nullmote im Kabel genommen.
Also quasi zwei PCs per parallel Port verbunden mit und hat sich übelst gefeiert.
Da konnte man dann Half-Life 1 übers Netzwerk kopieren.
Mit innerhalb von zweieinhalb Stunden oder so.
It's pro Sekunde wohlgemerkt.
Nicht Bits.
Boah.
Ich wollte damals immer einen Zip Drive haben.
Weil da konnte man 100 MB draufspeisen. Ich hatte nie einen Zip Drive.
Aber ich wollte damals immer einen Zip Drive haben. Ich habe keine Ahnung wofür ich es hätte verwendet, wenn ich es hätte.
Aber ich wollte es immer haben, weil 100 MB sau viel waren.
Ja, jetzt ist das Problem mit dran.
Was ist das für ein Switch?
Wartet mal Leute, was ist das?
Das ist eine Soundkarte mit Joystick Anschluss.
PS2 Serial Parallel?
Modem? Das ist ein RJ11 Stecker.
Das ist ein Modem?
Und könnte das hier eine Grafikkarte sein?
Was ist das hier oben?
Eine uralte TV-Karte?
Das könnte echt eine Grafikkarte sein, oder?
Ich sehe sonst keinen Grafikausgang hier dran.
Was ist hier wahrscheinlich ein Modem?
Die Werbung damals.
Achso, ja Leute, ich habe ganz vergessen.
Ich muss mal Streamlabs aufmachen, falls irgendjemand heute gesabt, gefollowed, gesonst was ist.
Nicht, dass ich es ganz komplett vergesse.
Zum Glück habe ich nichts übersehen.
Danke für die Follows.
Ich bin heute am Start dem Chuck 690 und ich bin es ein Fischi.
Sehr schön.
15 Volt.
Oh, jetzt hat aber einer gesabbt.
Perfekt, 271 Twitch Prime Sub.
Dazu kann ich bloß sagen.
Nice, danke für den Sub.
Sie haben es damals nicht auch schon wieder verkackt mit Anschlüssen.
Wisst ihr was?
Damals haben die Leute schon gedacht, Alter, das ist aber eine fette Karte.
Hätten die gewusst, dass Grafikkarten heute drei Slots brauchen und quasi über Gehäusespezifikationen gehen,
hätten sie mir das nicht geglaubt.
Timilos, danke für den Twitch Prime Sub.
Auch hier nice.
Ultra nice.
Drei Slots kann Grafikkarten heute.
Das ist überhaupt kein Ding mit dem fetten Lüfter drauf.
Ich meine, die sagen nicht drei Slots, die sagen zwei und halb Slots.
Was? Aber im Endeffekt, weil einen halben Slot gibt es nicht.
Das sind dann einfach nur drei Slots.
Was für ein riesen Anschluss.
Ist das eklig, dreckig.
Aber das Zeug hat damals echt schnell gegilbt.
Das lag aber auch mit daran, dass damals noch viel mehr Leute geraucht haben.
Beste.
36K.
33,6K, oder was war das?
Was war das hier?
33,6, ja.
Pock.
Modem Cosplay.
Das sind ganze Klinkenports.
Aktuellen hätten wir es nicht mehr.
Damals war alles, wenn du nicht Soundplaster kompatibel hattest, konntest du vergessen.
Oh ja, jawoll.
Hat ja bis heute überlebt im Endeffekt mit Zata.
Bloß, bloß.
Nicht extern.
Haha.
Die Werbung damals.
Wahnsinn, USB 1.0.
Das ist der größte Milchmann hab ich auch.
Ja.
Firewire.
Stimmt, das gab es ja auch noch.
Uiuiui, USB 2.0.
Ja.
Dafür gibt's halt mittlerweile 3 Milliarden verschiedene USB Stecker.
Das war ein tolles Video.
Das ist echt cool.
Big old servers.
Oh, das müssen wir jetzt noch gucken.
Ach so old sind die Dinger hier gar nicht.
Ist das ein Playcenter?
Ist das ein Playcenter, da müsste die Playcenter eigentlich vorne haben, aber von der Größe her.
Gucken wir mal.
Ich glaube, ich würde ziemlich doof angeguckt werden, wenn ich bei uns ins LZ gehe, mein Handy raushole und ein paar Server filme und dann hochlade.
Ja, genau, Max Reaction.
Team Ilius, danke für den Privance Up.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ich schon erzählt habe, aber ich habe es gerade in der Übersicht gesehen.
Falls ich vergessen habe, dann habe ich jetzt nachgeholt.
Das ist eine 4 HE Kiste.
Oder sogar noch mehr.
Das glaubte sogar noch mehr als 4.
Na, wobei.
Na, nee, 4.
Ist 4, würde ich auch sagen.
IBM hatte auch Kisten, die sich nicht so ganz dran gehalten haben.
Ihre Playzenders waren teilweise dann irgendwie auch 16 hoch und sowas.
Oder nicht 16, 8 hoch.
Erstmal den Hood poppen, genau.
Ja, die Öffnung kenne ich noch.
Das hatten die ganzen ollen IBM-Dinger.
Ganz wichtig, Leute.
Wenn ihr jemals in die Verlegenheit kommt, bei IBM einen Service-Request oder Service-Call aufmachen zu müssen,
ihr braucht die Nummer hier oben.
Das ist die sogenannte Frunummer.
Die Frunummer ist das Einzige, was dem indischen IBM Support überhaupt sagt, was ihr wollt.
Ihr könnt noch so viele Wörter verwenden, das ist egal.
Die Frunummer ist das, was zählt.
Ohne Frunummer IBM Support nichts wissen.
Classic IBM.
Dieses System, wie ich gesagt habe, von 2011 bis 2012.
Das wurde bevor ich hier angefangen habe.
Aber es ist auch schon vor der Lenovo-Besuchung.
Du weißt ja, Lenovo hat IBMs Computer-Hardware-Business aufgebildet.
Und also ist das ein echter IBM-System.
Ich erinnere mich an, dass ich einen Hood anrufen wollte.
Und ich habe eigentlich mit IBM gesprochen, das war eine Spam-Type.
Das erste, was diesen Boxen interessant macht, ist dieses Setup.
Es ist doch ein Playcenter? Ist es doch ein Playcenter? Sah gar nicht so aus, ne?
Das ist doch ein Playcenter, das ist gerade eine Erweiterung.
Ihr hattet auch mal so ein Ding, also in Vollaufbau.
Das waren ein paar Testkisten, auch so 2012 oder 2011, also schon eine ganze Weile her.
Und die hatten jetzt ohne Scheiß zu dieser Zeit damals 2TB RAM.
Das ging natürlich nur, wenn du das mit 64G Modulen voll bestückt hattest,
die kompletten Erweiterungsbänke voll.
Ich will nicht wissen, was 2TB RAM damals gekostet haben.
Das war immer noch ordentlich.
Das war wirklich ganz cool bei den Dingern damals von IBM.
Du konntest sie komplett ohne zu schrauben, das meiste.
I bims meri, das war ja eine Datenbank-Geschichte.
Stimmt nicht, die 2TB RAM-Kiste war nicht für eine Datenbank damals,
die war für irgendwelche Citrix-Virtualisierungsgeschichten,
die 2TB RAM-Kiste damals, die wir hatten zum Testen.
Wir hatten nicht nur eine Kiste zum Testen, ich glaube wir hatten zehn oder so.
Das war für irgendwelche Citrix-Dinger.
Die IBM-Dinger sind echt nicht schlecht.
Du kannst das alles ohne Werkzeug austauschen, das meiste.
Hier haben wir vier Heatsinks.
Was ich mag, ist, dass sie den Erweiterungshändler aufnehmen.
Sollte sich jemand fragen, wie das mit dem Kühlen überhaupt funktioniert,
das ist eigentlich relativ einfach.
Der Luftstrom geht da einfach so durch von vorne nach hinten.
Vorne saugst du es an und hinten hast du dann eine Klimaanlage, die es absaugt wieder.
Oder warte mal, wo ist überhaupt hinten und wo ist vorne? Ach hier ist vorne, sorry, hier ist vorne.
Hier ist vorne, dann zieht es das so rum.
Und die Dinger sind laut.
Also die Dinger sind wirklich laut, da ist man Staubsauger-Roboter von gestern nix dagegen.
Das ist ein 8-Core, 2 Gigahertz Prozessor mit Hyper-Threading, also 16 Threads.
Einfach.
Multipiere das.
Dieser Server hat 32 Cores, 64 Threads.
Jetzt, nachdem, was AMD und Intel so tun, kannst du jetzt einen hübschen Numer von Cores aus einem einzigen CPU bekommen.
Aber erinner dich an 2012.
Ja, das stimmt.
Das war viel Computer-Kompetenz in einer einzigen Box.
Also vier CPUs, ein einziges Heatsink für jedes.
Jetzt, du hast mich gedacht, okay, also dieser Server, du weißt, es ist ein ziemlich kniffliger Box, eine Menge RAM, eine Menge CPU.
Also, okay, was ist mit der Storage?
Es muss nur ein paar Hard Drives und so weiter drin sein, oder?
Also, wenn wir nach vorne schauen, ist es ein bisschen dunkel, aber man kann sehen, wir haben hier diese Drive Bays.
Hier sind acht von denen.
Sie nehmen 2,5 Inch SAS-Drives.
Aber wenn wir...
Die Dinger, du kannst da bestimmt auch ohne Probleme, ohne Probleme eine Fiber Channel Karte und Zeugs einbauen, dass du da mehr Storage...
Wie schwer ist so eine Kiste?
Ziemlich schwer.
Also, die weiß ich jetzt nicht, aber ich habe mal einen IBM Playcenter alleine eingebaut, als ich noch als Ruby war.
Das war so ein Ding.
Ja, genau, so ein Teil.
Das sind acht HE.
Und das ist wirklich schwer, das Ding.
Ich würde mal sagen, so 50 Kilo oder so.
Max Electronics kann ich machen, ja.
Ich schreibe es nochmal falsch, ich vergesse.
Ich würde mal sagen, so 50 Kilo.
Das ist ein Sehres, ja.
Und 5 Kilo ist eher ein einzelnes Plate, was da drin steckt.
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob 50 Kilo überhaupt reichen.
Ja, 85 Kilo.
Das trifft es eher.
Ich sage euch, Leute, das war nicht ohne.
Und das Einbauen kannst du auch nicht so einfach machen.
Also, das kannst du nicht machen wie bei...
Normale Surfer kannst du halbwegs einfach in den Rack einbauen.
Wenn du...
Machst du Schienen rein.
Und je nachdem, wie das Ganze gemacht ist, wie gut die Schienen sind, kannst du es einfach vorne richtig rein machen und gut ist.
Oder manche Dinger musst du auch so halb mit einem Arm reinhalten und dann festschrauben, ja.
Aber die Plate Center, die musst du reinheben in die Schienen.
Das war nicht so easy.
Und die IBM Schienen damals hatten auch, vielleicht waren es auch nur unsere, hatten die Angewohnheit, dass es mal ganz gerne verkantet ist und mal ganz gerne hängen geblieben ist.
Da musstest du es dann reinheben in der Hoffnung, dass du es gleichmäßig reinhebst, dass es auf beiden Seiten richtig passt, sonst musstest du dran ziehen und sowas.
Das war schon nicht ohne.
Aber ohne Scheiß, Leute, wenn ich das so sehe, ich muss sagen, ich mache ja die letzten, ich mache ja schon 10 Jahre nichts mehr richtig mit Hardware, ja.
Also ein bisschen vermisse ich das schon, ja.
Also vor allem, als ich noch Azubi war, und das ist jetzt ja noch, noch länger her.
Ähm...
Oder ganz knapp so lange her.
Da war ich so viel im RZ und habe so viel an Hardware herumgeschraubt, irgendwie vermisse ich das schon ein bisschen.
Einfach so, da musstest du dir um viel weniger politische Befindlichkeiten irgendwie Gedanken machen, ja.
Ähm...
Was irgendwie das eine irgendwas will, der andere will irgendwas nicht.
So bei Hardware ist es im Prinzip kein Ding.
Du weißt, ah, CPU kaputt, CPU austauschen.
Oder Platte kaputt, Platte austauschen.
Die Dinge haben auch alle, ähm, gut bei dem hier weiß ich nicht.
Aber die meisten dieser IBM-Kisten haben vorne auch Status-LEDs, dass du genau siehst, was kaputt ist.
Also in dem Fall muss man sagen, das ist gar nicht mal komplett überteuerte Server-Hardware.
Die waren auch gut, die Dinger.
Die waren wirklich nicht übel.
Und der ist schon relativ neu, der hat zumindest schon vorne einen USB-Anschluss.
Ähm...
Weil wie gesagt, die Anschlüsse bei den meisten Sachen sind natürlich, sind vorne.
Manche Hersteller haben das auch nicht gecheckt, haben die Anschlüsse immer noch hinten hingemacht.
Aber es ist Absicht, dass die Anschlüsse vorne sind.
Manche hatten sogar noch hier unten so ein Mini, so ein Laptop-CD-Laufwerk drinne.
Ähm...
Ach nee, da drüben ist schon die HP-Kiste.
Sieht ein bisschen aus wie ein DL3.
Ah nee, ist kein DL3-80.
Ähm...
Zumindest...
...hatst du die Anschlüsse halt vorne, weil das ist halt das, was du aus dem Rack rausgucken hast.
Ja, das ist normal.
Naja, entweder hat es...
Es hat eine Fiber-Channel dran.
Oder...
Wenn wir das wieder öffnen...
...und du schaust sehr vorsichtig drunter, siehst du ein paar USB-Ports.
Das hier sieht aus wie ein USB-Stick.
Es ist ziemlich so.
In der Industrie nennt es eine DOM oder Disk-On-Memory.
Dieser hier, denke ich, ist zwei Gigabyte.
Und das ist das einzige Stück der Stärke, das dieser Server in ihm hat.
Die Idee ist, dass du einfach dein Operierungssystem von da aus bootst.
Das haben wir nicht groß verwendet.
Und was machst du jetzt auf Arbeit?
Ben, ich mache mal ein Ausrufezeichen Beruf.
Da habe ich mal versucht zu erklären.
Klingt logisch.
Da hat es viele Virtual-Maschinen.
Es gibt viel RAM und viel CPU-Kraft.
Aber es braucht keinen Disk.
Alle Virtual-Maschinen, wie ihre Storage,
wurden auf einem separaten System, genannt San oder Storage Area Network.
Es ist ein Server, das eine ganze Menge Hard-Drives oder SSDs hat.
Und das Ziel ist es, diese Files zu nutzen,
für Dinge wie Hypervisors, um Files zu accessieren.
... und so weiter.
Aber all diese Server und alle, die nebenan sind,
haben keine Hard-Drives drin,
weil sie alle ihre Hard-Drives auf dem Sand bekommen würden.
Schauen wir uns zurück.
Und hier sieht man, wir haben hier einiges mehr Netzwerke.
Mehr Netzwerkarten, bitte.
... und so weiter.
Was mir hinten auch schön sieht, ist,
dass du die Netzteile einfach austauschen kannst.
Das Ding hat zwei Netzteile, machst einfach hoch,
ziehst Netzteil raus und es läuft trotzdem weiter.
Und du hast auch überall Status-LEDs,
wo du siehst, ob etwas kaputt ist.
VR, ILO-Port.
Wobei, nee, warte mal.
Wie heißt das bei IBM?
ILO ist, glaube ich, RSA, hieß das bei IBM.
Oder?
Oder war es ILO bei IBM?
Das Management-Interface im Endeffekt.
Du hast da auch ein Management-Web-Interface,
wo du alles mögliche auf dem Server einstellen kannst.
Und dann hast du da noch mal hinten...
Das habe ich damals nicht verstanden.
Warum macht man VGA hinten?
Man hätte VGA vorne und VGA hinten machen sollen,
weil viele sind mit einem Wagen rumgelaufen,
haben sich per Monitor und Tastatur angestöpselt
und einige hatten auch in ihren Racks
so ein KVM-Switch-System.
Das heißt eigentlich hast du VGA-Ports
vorne und hinten gebraucht.
Das einzige Problem daran war, dass fast alles Java-basiert war.
Also das ganze Management-Ding.
Ich meine, die Webseite war natürlich eine Webseite,
aber sobald du ein bisschen mehr machen wolltest,
war das alles Java-basiert.
Und ich glaube, das ist auch der Grund,
warum man Hass auf Java herkommt,
weil diese Remote-Management-Geschichten
in Java nie richtig funktioniert haben.
Die Dinger haben immer übelste netzteile drin.
Mich würde nicht wundern,
wenn das ein 1200 Watt-Netzteil links und rechts ist.
Die haben da immer
die oversized-Netzteile überhaupt drin gehabt.
Auch nur 875, easy.
Ach nee, 2000, 2000.
Die haben da immer
so krass fette Netzteile drin
in den Dingern.
Das heißt, du kannst einen von ihnen verlieren, und der Server bleibt auf und ab.
Wenn der Power Supply verfehlt,
vielleicht auch die Nutzung der Kraft,
die das füttert, kann es verfehlen, was auch immer.
Der ganze Server bleibt auf und ab.
Also wird das Ganze bis zum Maximum
ca. zwei Kilowatts von Kraft nehmen.
Das ist ziemlich viel Juice,
und es gibt auch einiges von Heat.
Es gibt also verschiedene Fans
durch das System.
Die Power Supply selbst hat Fans gebaut.
Und dann, was die RAM und die CPU coolt,
da diese nicht mit Fans gebaut haben,
ist das hier an der Front.
Mal sehen, ob ich das mit einer Hand machen kann.
Du kannst diese Tabs drücken.
Das ist echt gut gewesen, das Zeug.
Ach guck mal, hier unten haben sie doch ein CD-Laufwerk noch drin.
Das Zeug war wirklich gut.
Ihr seht ja, du kannst das alles
ohne Werkzeug tauschen.
Also, da ist schon ein System dahinter,
und da hat man sich schon was bei gedacht.
Und natürlich sind diese auch
sehr floppig.
Das ist ein guter Fan.
Das ist das, was die Luft
durch die Front des Systems
und aus der Rückseite
drücken kann.
Server sind generell
Front-to-Back,
also geht all das kühle Luft
durch die Front,
wird durch alle Komponenten drückt,
und dann kommt das heiße Luft
aus der Rückseite,
und dann wird es umgekehrt.
Hier ist die Sicht von den PCI-Karten.
Und da sind ein paar Schläge, die wir nicht benutzen.
Also hier sehen wir die anderen Server
auf dieser Karte.
Ich müsste mal den Felix fragen, ob wir sowas bei uns in der Zeit auch aufnehmen können.
Das wäre doch mal was, oder?
MaxRZTour.
Was kostet so ein Server?
Boah, keine Ahnung.
Ich würd mal sagen, so
20k oder so?
Mit ordentlicher Ausstattung.
20.000? Oder mehr?
Irgendwie so in dem Dreh ist schwer zu sagen.
20.000?
Was hat er jetzt, die HP-Dinger oder?
Habt ihr ein eigenes RZ?
Jaja, wir haben sogar zwei RZs
in Frankfurt.
Jetzt nicht
riesengroße,
aber unser eines RZ besteht
aus 3 Räumen,
das eine ist
ne, aus 4 Räumen.
Das eine ist ein relativ großes Lager,
das andere ist ein kleines Lager,
das andere ist der große Raum
mit allen Rechnern drin und allen Racks,
und das andere, der vierte Raum, ist
das, wo noch ein bisschen mehr Technik drin steht.
Und das andere RZ
ist ähnlich.
Also, flächenmäßig sind die RZ
schon ziemlich groß, aber man könnte wahrscheinlich
noch eine ganze Ecke mehr Hardware reinbauen.
Ne, haben wir nicht.
Kein Arm.
War das jetzt die HP-Kiste,
die er aufgemacht hat?
Ne, ne, oder?
Doch,
die HP-Kiste hat er aufgemacht.
Wie viel Anbindung
haben eure RZ so?
Ist ne gute Frage, ich weiß gar nicht, was wir aktuell haben.
Also, wir hatten jahrelang
hatten wir
im
quasi für das
für das, für das, für das Gebäude,
wo die meisten Leute drin gesessen haben,
war 2 Gigabit.
Allerdings,
mittlerweile dürfte das
viel mehr sein.
Also nicht ins RZ, sondern da,
wo die Leute drin gesessen haben.
RZ ist mit Sicherheit mehr.
Ah, crap.
Ich hab die eingebauten Ratinger
nie verwendet, wenn sie anders gingen.
Ach, das hab ich noch nicht gesehen.
Das hab ich noch nicht gesehen, die SD-Karte, die man da reinstecken kann.
Das wär jetzt neu.
Also, ihr seht, wir haben ein paar mehr
PCIe-Kart-Slots
in hier.
Dieser hat zwei Backplanes.
Was anders ist
an dieser Box als die IBM,
ist die Selektion
von Netzwerken auf dem Backen.
Das sieht
für mich aus wie
...
Das ist doch ganz normal, er hat 45 Ports, aber sieht irgendwie nicht so aus, sieht ein bisschen breiter aus.
Übrigens Leute, wir sehen es hier, VGA und PS2.
4200 Watt Netzteile.
Ja gut, das haben alle.
Ah, hier zeigt das.
Das habe ich noch nie gesehen.
Das X5, wo du diese separate Daughter-Karten für den RAM hast, es gibt acht von ihnen. In diesem Fall sind es alle 8 GB RAM Stücke, ein bisschen schneller RAM, aber es ist immerhin DDR3 ECC.
Das ist cool, dann siehst du welcher RAM kaputt ist.
Ich meine ganz ehrlich, bei diesen vielen RAM-Riegel, da drinnen blickt ja kein Mensch durch, welcher RAM jetzt kaputt ist.
Das ist ein schönes Video. Ich glaube die meisten Leute haben so etwas einfach schlicht und gerade noch nicht gesehen.
RZ Hardware hat irgendwie was. Die wirkt einfach an vielen Stellen, was das mechanisch angeht, ziemlich durchdacht.
Ich meine, dass du die ganzen Gehäuse halb auseinander nehmen kannst, die meisten selber halb auseinander nehmen kannst, ohne dass du Werkzeug brauchst, ist schon geil.
Auf der anderen Seite wirkt da vieles Zeug wie aus dem letzten Jahrtausend. Das ist ganz merkwürdig.
Auf der einen Seite wirkt das richtig cool und durchdacht und dann guckst du dir die Kisten an und hast heute VGA-Anschlüsse und PS2-Anschlüsse oder Sachen, die nur mit Java richtig funktionieren.
Wie gesagt, die neuen Dell-Kisten, die haben jetzt seit einer Weile schon eine HTML5-Oberfläche und auch eine Remote-Konsole mit HTML5.
Aber ich meine, das ist 2019. Das hätten wir seit 10 Jahren schon machen können. Wenn einer, was Technik angeht, sehr konservativ ist, dann sind das Server-Hersteller.
So, jetzt gucken wir mal als nächstes. Was habe ich hier noch drinne?
Was ist das?
Was ist das? Okay, ich habe in meiner später Ansehen-Liste noch einen Videolink drinne, wo ich keine Ahnung habe, was es ist. Also es könnte jetzt sein, dass es Monka Toss ist.
Was zum Teufel ist das? Gwen131, danke für den Twitch Prime-Sub. Was zum Teufel ist das?
Was zum Teufel ist das? Gwen131, danke für den Twitch Prime-Sub. Was zum Teufel ist das? Battle-Bots-Basement.
Ach, das ist diese, oh nee, ich weiß, was das ist. Das ist diese komische Fight-Sendung, wo sie so kleine Roboter gegeneinander rennen lassen. Wobei, das ist witzig.
Jaja. Genau, das ist wo sich diese komischen Roboter gegeneinander fahren lassen. Das ist echt ganz unterhaltsam. Okay, die Ansage müssen wir nicht gucken. Wir gucken uns jetzt mal das.
Das Match an, ja. Genau, der Kram ist da. Warum habe ich das in meiner später Ansehen-Liste drinne? Und was ist das für ein Ding? Was zum Teufel soll das sein? Und warum ist das Interlaced-Video?
WTF?
Wow, es brennt.
Er sieht nicht sonderlich elegant aus, muss man sagen, ne?
Woran erkennst du, dass es Interlaced ist, wenn es Streifen hat bei schneller Bewegung?
Was ein Kram! WTF, ey?
Okay, Moment, Moment, Musik, Musik, wartet mal. Das, das, das, das, äh, mehr generikste Metal-Ding zum Unterlegen von sowas, ey.
Das sieht so behäbig aus irgendwie.
Vor allem, wie das Ding versucht, damit aufzustehen.
Das sieht wirklich aus wie ein Mülleimer. Das Ding sieht echt aus wie Mülleimer. Oh, jetzt wird er abgefackelt.
Haben die sich irgendwie gerade ein bisschen verhakt?
Das sieht so aus, der Kämpf gegen Frosch. Das sieht echt so aus. Oh, jetzt. Grip. Grip. Kaputt.
Kommt das noch mal hoch, das Ding?
Warum genau guck ich mir das jetzt an? Die Konstruktion von dem Teil wirkt noch nicht so ganz ausgereift.
Das Grill hat gewonnen. Oh Mann. Was es für ein Kram gibt, ey.
Was es für ein Kram gibt. Jetzt wird erstmal in die Luft Flammen werfert.
Jetzt wird in die Luft gehackt. Macht das Ding hier auch irgendwas?
Außer, das ist abgefackelt. Er sieht schon irgendwie ein bisschen behäbig aus, oder?
Oh, er hat sich selbst kaputt gemacht. Es hat sich selbst zerstört.
Es hat sich selbst zerstört. Der andere hat überhaupt nichts gemacht. Der andere hat einfach nur da gestanden.
Es hat sich selbst zerstört. Vorbei. Kennst du AVE? Nee, sagt mir nichts. Was ist AVE? Alien versus Alien?
Tja, er hat sich ausgechommt, würde ich sagen. Der musste nicht wirklich was machen.
Der musste einfach nur da stehen, während sich der andere selbst zerstört.
Moment, die haben einen Typ, der den auszählt, oder was?
Was es alles gibt. Was es alles gibt.
Sponsoren die das oder heißen die einfach so?
Mir fällt nichts ein, was das andere sein könnte.
Warum existiert sowas überhaupt? Irgendwo ist es ganz unterhaltsam.
Warum gibt es sowas? Pizza-Karton, ja. Pizza-Karton. Geht es nicht mal UFO, das ist so ein Kreisel, wie es früher für die Kinder gab, so zum aufpumpen und dann...
Warum existiert so eine Fernsehsendung? Warum gibt es die?
Wer kommt auf die Idee vor allem, sowas zu machen? Ich meine, unterhaltsam ist es irgendwo. Aber ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass ich mir das zwei Stunden am Stück angucke.
Oh, jetzt ist es vorbei. Oh, es lebt noch.
Das UFO ist richtig OP, ja.
Oh, es ist... Ich glaube, die Räder beim UFO sind kaputt.
Es bewegt sich nicht mehr.
Das UFO hat sich ausgeufoert. Es dreht sich noch, aber es fährt nicht mehr.
Aber drehen tut sich noch.
Der Counter-Typ. Was es nicht alles gibt.
Warum nicht?
Aber schon... Was es nicht alles gibt.
Das ist ein Knockout. Ich meine, es dreht sich zwar auf der Stelle noch.
Mal gucken, ob hier mein... Elektro-Boom neue Videos hat.
Nee, hat er nicht. Kenne ich alles schon. Wie gesagt, den Channel kann man echt empfehlen.
Wer sich für ein bisschen Elektronik-Krams interessiert, Videos, die unterhaltsam sind.
Mal eins gucken.
Das wird der Dusch immer auch nice.
USB-Killer.
Oh Gott.
Ups.
Ich weiß jetzt schon, dass er sich mindestens 20 Mal selber schockt in dem Video.
Die Hose brennt.
Da hat er recht.
Hä, das ist doch gestellt. Nee, das ist bei dem in jedem Video so. Der ist hart im Nehmen. Natürlich ist es... Naja, was heißt gestellt? Ihm wird schon klar sein, dass es keine gute Idee ist, aber der macht das wirklich.
Monka Smoke ist bei dem angesagt.
Sein, sein Herd nimmt er auch gern auseinander. Das hat er in ganz, in ganz vielen Videos nimmt er sein Herd immer auseinander.
Das ist Absicht. Das ist aber nicht gestellt, in dem Sinn, dass es fake wäre.
Das kann ich mir vorstellen.
Wie ist der Typ noch am Leben? Ganz einfach, der weiß, was er macht.
Wie gesagt, die Videos sind echt unterhaltsam, aber man lernt auch viel.
Das kommt fast jeden laufend in seinen Videos.
Genau, Oszilloskop Sellout kommt auch immer.
Und so, wenn ich diese beiden Kontakte schaue, wird die Lichtung aufgeschaltet. Und wenn ich probiere, ohne mich zu schockieren... Oh, sie teilen den gleichen Grund. Ich brauche nicht den Grund zu verbinden.
Okay, nun, die gelbe Linie ist die Input-Voltage und die rote ist der Output. Und wenn ich es anstehe, sieht man, dass, wenn ich den Dimmer schalte, ein Teil des Outputs ausgeschaltet ist.
Hier im Minimum und hier im Maximum. Und so reduziert dies den effektiven AC-Voltage-Output über eine resistive Lobe.
Er erklärt auch die Sachen zwischendrin immer richtig gut.
Und in diesem Fall ist es ein Triac, welches ein bi-direktionaler Schalter ist. Zu viele Worte?
Zuletzt ist es ein Open-Circuit zwischen den beiden Hauptterminalen, bis du einen Schalter in den Schalter-Terminal sendest. Und dann wird er geschlossen und bleibt an, solange du den Schalter durch den Schalter runnst.
Was hast du schon Alan Masks Neuralink gesehen? Nee? Neuralink klingt hier.
Ich hoffe, ihr habt aufgepasst. Nächsten Stream wird das Ganze abgefragt.
Er ist phase-shifted und dreht sich 0, wenn der Voltage am Peak ist.
Okay, mal sehen, was der neue Dimmer anders macht.
Er macht die selbe Scheiße.
Also was? Es ist kompatibel mit LED-Lasern, weil die neuen LED-Lasern designt zu werden. Und das nimmt den Kredit? Was zur Hölle?
Keine Live-Circuits, weil sie das machen können. Mal sehen, was die Differenzen zwischen demabel und nicht-dimmable LED-Lasern sind. Ich werde verschiedene Lichter mit meiner Kamera im Slow-Motion filmen, um zu sehen, welche Differenzen wir sehen.
Hier ist der Inkandescent. Wie erwartet, ändert sich die Hölle durch den AC-Zykel. Hier ist der dimmable LED. Er bewegt sich wie der Inkandescent. Und hier ist der un-dimmable Licht. Und sein Ausblutlicht ist konstant.
Also die dimmable LED-Lasern sind aufgrund des AC-Voltages ausgestattet. Deswegen können wir sie mit der Veränderung des AC-Voltages dimmen.
Aber der un-dimmable LED bewegt sich schlecht an einem Dimmer, weil er aufgrund des AC-Voltages ausgestattet ist.
Also sieht man, dass er konstant ist. Aber bei sehr niedrigen AC-Voltagen ist er schlecht. Beide haben ihre eigenen Vorteile. Eine ermöglicht Dimmabilität, während die andere ermöglicht eine feste Ausblutwerte, unabhängig von den Inputflaktuationen.
Wir reden damit, dass sein Klemmen immer am Start ist.
Ich glaube die Frage, die man sich nicht stellen darf, ist warum man sowas machen sollte, sondern eigentlich weil es geht.
Wir haben hier zwei Stück Steine, die man mit dem Knopf anstecken kann. Wir brauchen nicht mehr als eine Hälfte.
So, jetzt muss man das Ding in eine Kugel schieben, um sich zu fühlen und zu sitzen.
Auf der anderen Seite, wenn jemand die Steine auslösen lässt und sie auf Maximum setzt, kann es den Heater oder den Dimmer überheaten und das Haus auf Feuer setzen.
Wir könnten ein sehr gutes System entwickeln, in dem ein Mikro-Kontroller die Temperatur des Heater-Elementes und die Ausblutwerte der PWM kontrolliert, um genau die Temperatur zu kontrollieren,
indem man mit einem komponenten und fehlsafe Kontroll-Algorithm arbeitet.
Wer glaubt, dass ich jeden Tag schlauer bin?
Ich brauche nur einen dieser Futter-Temperatur-Sensoren, die ich mit meinem Heater-Element verbinden.
Siehst du, was ich getan habe? Ich habe die Heater-Elemente geschnitten und das Glas entfernt, und ich habe auch hier ein Stück Heater-Elementen verbunden, das jetzt bewegen kann.
Und normalerweise kann diese Heater-Elemente frei bewegen, wenn die Temperatur hochkommt.
Aber jetzt, wenn die Temperatur hochkommt, wird die Heater-Elemente an diesem Stück Heater-Elementen gestoppt.
Also kann die Temperatur nicht mehr hochkommen, weil die Heater-Elemente gestoppt ist.
Ist das so, wie es funktioniert?
Nein!
Weil wenn die Heater-Elemente gestoppt ist, könnte die Temperatur hochkommen.
Es zeigt es einfach nicht. Ich glaube, wir müssen besser machen.
Hier habe ich noch eine Sache gemacht.
Ich habe hier ein Stück Heater-Elementen verbunden, mit dem Schaft dieses Dinges, das auch an die Heater-Elemente gestoppt ist.
Jetzt, wenn die Temperatur hochkommt, wird die Heater-Elemente an diesem Stück Heater-Elementen gestoppt.
Hier ist das Plan.
Ich habe einen normal geschlossenen Schaft, der die Heater-Elemente gestoppt und ihr Schaft durch einen Diode, Resistor und Kapazitor gestoppt wird.
Ich halte auch den Schaft, damit ich die Temperatur hochkomme.
Jetzt, was passiert ist, ist, wenn ich den AC verbinden, wird die Heater-Elemente gestoppt und heizt,
wie auch mein Thermal-Schaft, das mit dem Schaft verbunden ist.
Wenn die Temperatur den Schaft, den ich mit meinem Thermal-Schaft verbunden habe, erreicht, dass der Schaft die Heater-Elemente gestoppt und die Heater-Elemente gestoppt wird.
Jetzt wird die Heater-Elemente gestoppt und wenn die Heater-Elemente unter dem Schaft gestoppt wird, wird der Schaft geöffnet und die Heater-Elemente gestoppt und die Heater-Elemente gestoppt wird.
Also, man könnte dazu quasi fast schon sagen...
Es funktioniert!
Nicht schlecht!
Ich weiß nicht, ich würde mich da nicht draufsetzen, unbedingt.
Es funktioniert!
Das ist wirklich ein guter Channel.
Wenn er nicht gestoppt ist...
Ich kann ihn zappen, das ist echt nice.
So, was hat er denn gefunden?
Was Aaron Musk Neuralink habe ich schon.
Was soll das sein?
Aaron Musk will uns ans Gehirn.
Versuch ein Mensch bereits nächstes Jahr...
Was?
Was, was, was, was hat er vor?
Ich mein, es wäre ja schonmal cool, wenn er die anderen Sachen mal irgendwie soweit fertig macht.
Aber egal, du musst immer neues Zeug basteln.
Ein Brain-to-Computer-Interface.
Gib dir die Präsentation.
Okay.
Wie ist das Ding?
Ach, nicht nur Neuralink.
Okay.
Moment.
Hat der Typ den Fernseher gefilmt, kann das sein?
Nee.
Also das wird jetzt auch das letzte, was ich machen würde.
Ich würde garantiert Aaron Musk nicht an mein Hirn lassen.
Moment, das gehörte schon dazu.
Setz dich in die Kugel.
Okay.
Äh, setzen die da grad irgendwie einem was ein in den Kopf oder was ist das?
Äh.
Glückwunsch zur Partnerschaft, Dankeschön.
Hab ich euch übrigens schon erzählt, dass wenn ihr einen Twitch, ähm, wenn ihr einen Amazon Prime-Account habt,
dass ihr den umsonst mit Twitch verbinden könnt und dann kriegt ihr Twitch Prime Loot kostenlos
und ihr könnt einmal im Monat einen Streamer eurer Wahl mit einem Twitch Prime-Sub unterstützen.
Was ist das für eine Auflösung?
Schaffen die es nicht, ihre super High-Tech-Präsentation mit einer Kamera aufzunehmen, die auch ordentliche, ordentliche, äh,
oh, ich hab, hab einen Sub gesubbt.
Sync XP Twitch Prime, Dankeschön.
Hi Sue.
Ich hab das Gefühl, ich hab ja schon ein paar Präsentationen geguckt, ne?
Ich hab das Gefühl, die, die Präsentation, woran das steht,
die bestehen in der Regel im Publikum immer nur als, nur so als, zum größten aus irgendwelchen Einschleim-Leute, ja?
Weil du hast immer Leute im Publikum sitzen, wenn er irgendwie so einen billigen Joke macht, siehst du,
hörst du immer Leute im Publikum, hohohoho, und so was.
Okay, jetzt, jetzt erklären sie uns, was das Ding ist.
Ja gut, das hat man, das lernt man sogar in der Schule schon.
Also, zumindest wenn man aufgepasst hat.
Pock, ein echtes neuronales Netz.
Easy.
Naja, ja, natürlich hast du auch blaue Lichter im Kopf.
Ich mein, du hast da noch nicht reingeguckt, ich mein, du weißt gar nicht, ob das so ist.
Und die Pressekonferenzen von dem, oder die, die Präsentationen von dem sind immer so übelst langweilig.
Ich fand auch diese, wir fliegen zur Mars-Präsentation übelst langweilig.
Wisst ihr was, Leute, wir lesen uns jetzt mal durch, um was es bei der Sache überhaupt geht.
Ich hab kein Bock, die Präsentation mir anzugucken.
Also, was, was, was will er machen?
Wie von 2016 gegründet, will ein indirektes Interface zwischen dem menschlichen Gehirn und dem Computer herstellen.
Ein Brain-to-Computer-Interface, okay, bla, bla, bla.
100 Millionen, das ist aber ganz schön wenig, oder?
Für so eine bahnbrechende neue Technik.
Der Roboter zum Implantieren der ultradünnen Fäden, welche den Signalaustausch ermöglichen sollen, tief ins Gehirn bereits...
Ey, der Satz ist komisch, oder?
Der Roboter zum Implantieren der ultradünnen Fäden, welche den Signalaustausch ermöglichen sollen, tief ins Gehirn ist bereits funktionsfähig und wurde von Laboraten...
Der Satz ist irgendwie komisch.
Zumindest will er irgendwelche Fäden ins Gehirn anbauen.
Aktuell ist es zum Implantieren der Fäden noch nötig, Löcher in den Schädel.
Also wenn ich irgendwie einen nicht an meinen Kopf lassen würde, dann garantiert ihn.
Ähm, die Forscher hoffen aber dazu bald Laser nutzen zu können.
Da, fuck.
Und wozu?
2020 versuchender Menschen.
Tja, da finden sich genug Leute, die da freiwillig mitmachen.
Aus mehreren im Schädel implantierten Chips an den Fäden hängen, die in etwa der Größe einer Nervenzelle entsprechen.
An den Fäden sind Elektroden angebracht, die den Signalaustausch zwischen Neuralink und den Nervenzellen ermöglichen.
Ja, aber warum? Also was hat man denn davon jetzt?
So soll es möglich sein, etwa 40 Wörter pro Minute zu denken.
Also die neuesten, die quasi, die, das ist dann nicht Text to Speech, das ist dann Prane, ne ne ne, nicht, ähm, nicht Speech to Text.
Das ist dann Prane to Text.
Also, also, wenn das, wenn das Beste ist, was wir damit machen können, wenn Computer Wörter aufschreiben lassen können, dann ist, äh, naja.
Außerdem, wie schnell ist jemand, der gut tippen kann?
40 Wörter pro Minute?
Die Datenübertragung?
Bluetooth.
Das heißt, die Chips in meinem Hirn kommunizieren dann mit Bluetooth mit meinem Smartphone.
Yeah.
Das stimmt, das, das klingt tatsächlich sinnvoll.
Amputierten, blinden, tauben und stummen Menschen helfen später.
Ähm, wobei ich irgendwie so meine Bedenken habe, dass das tatsächlich das Ziel der ganzen Sache ist.
Daten ins Gehirn einfügen.
Bewegung aus dem Kampfsport? Ist es dann wie in Matrix? Ich kann Kung Fu.
Das wirkt für mich alles ziemlich vage, was das Ganze machen soll.
Das wirkt noch ziemlich vage.
An sich finde ich es nicht schlecht, in dieser Richtung natürlich das, das weiter zu forschen und zu gucken, was, was, ähm, was man machen kann.
Aber ich würde mich ehrlich gesagt nicht freiwillig melden.
Ich hoffe, das läuft nicht auf Windows.
Vielleicht kann man so in 100 Jahren Alzheimer heilen.
Ja, es gibt, stimmt, viele Möglichkeiten damit, was man da machen kann.
Man denkt, du bekommst Sub-Emotes.
Ähm, ich muss jetzt erstmal meinen Emote-Prefix approven lassen.
Und dann kann ich Sub-Emotes machen.
Und dann brauche ich noch ein Designer, der gute Emotes machen kann.
Was ist dein Prefix? Ich weiß ja nicht, was ich nehme.
Ich würde ja am liebsten Max nehmen, also mit 4, so wie auf YouTube, weil dann ist das schön einprägsam und man sich das gut merken kann.
Ähm, aber ich glaube, da ist bestimmt schon belegt.
Ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass da schon belegt ist.
Ich kann das gerade mal ausprobieren.
Partner.
Emotes.
Eindeutiges Prefix, Max.
Probieren wir mal aus, ob das funktioniert.
Stellt's.
Wupp.
Was ist besser, Wupp oder Max?
Max ist schon einprägsamer, oder?
Also ich würde sagen, wir machen Max.
Und wenn Max nicht geht, mal Wupp oder sowas.
Das Emote-Prefix ist bereits verwendet.
Bitte wähle ein anderes.
Geht schon mal nicht.
Da müssen wir mal im nächsten Stream uns Gedanken machen, was wir da nehmen.
Wupp, Wupp ist irgendwie...
Wupp?
Aber Wupp in Kombination kann man irgendwie wenig machen, oder?
Nee, das ist zu lang.
Es müssen drei Buchstaben sein.
Ich probiere mal Wupp.
Okay, Wupp würde funktionieren.
Dein Präfix wurde zur Genehmigung eingereicht.
Vielen Dank für deine Geduld.
Dann warten wir es mal ab.
Was, wir wollen aber 187 als Präfix?
Warum denn 187?
Was ist denn 187?
187.
Ich habe mir gerade was gelesen.
Max hat Hardcore-Brain-Lack.
Was passiert eigentlich, wenn man das Emote nimmt?
Ach, ich war auch noch so schlau und habe das eingestellt, dass das Seitenverhältnis erhalten bleibt.
Ich kann den jetzt gar nicht irgendwie umformen oder so.
Ja Leute, ich würde sagen, wir sind wach, oder?
Sind wir wach?
Ich würde sagen, wir sind wach.
Zwei Stunden.
Max, ich habe mal eine ganz andere Frage.
Warum sind es bei 144 Herzmonitoren eigentlich genau 144?
Wieso genau diese Zahl?
Ich würde sagen, das ist irgendeine Bandbreitengeschichte aus dem Bauch raus.
Aber so wirklich sicher bin ich mir da nicht.
Also ich rate jetzt mal und dann gucken wir nach.
Ich denke mal, das liegt daran, dass sie sich überlegt haben, was kriegen wir maximal durch eine DVI bzw. HDMI, was auch immer damals aktuell gewesen ist.
Wie kriegen wir da maximal durch bei 1080p, 32 Bit Farbtiefe und wie viel Mal pro Sekunde kriegen wir das da maximal durch?
Und ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass sie dann bei 144 gelandet sind.
Ich habe aber ehrlich gesagt keine Ahnung.
Der Knäherberg sagt 12, 24, 30, 60, 120, 144.
Ja, die Frage ist aber warum?
Patrick sagt auch, hat was mit Bandbreite zu tun.
Ja, das gehe ich auch von aus.
Willst du den Clip mal anschauen? Was denn für ein Clip, Evoli?
Weil es ein Vielfaches von 24 ist. Aha.
Ok, das könnte sein. Aber warum muss es ein Vielfaches von 24 sein?
60 ist auch kein Vielfaches von 24.
Wir fragen einfach mal Google, warum 144?
Wie kommt man auf den Wert 144 beim Monitor?
Was ist das für eine Seite?
Ah, weil es ein Vielfaches von 24 ist, 24 ist der Start für Filme.
Ok, es ist tatsächlich wohl liegt es daran, dass es ein Vielfaches von 24 ist.
Ja, und es hat was, dann passt das.
Man will den Vielfaches von 24 haben.
Und man hat das höchste Vielfaches von 24 gesucht, was über Dual Link DVI drüber geht.
Das ergibt Sinn.
Hey, 2003, also generell ist das gut, wenn es ein bisschen älter ist.
Weil die Frage ist ja auch schon ein bisschen älter.
Das klingt sinnvoll. Man hat einen Vielfaches von 24 gesucht.
Man hat das höchste Vielfaches von 24 gesucht, was bei Full HD über Dual Link DVI passt.
Das ergibt eigentlich Sinn.
Evoli, was soll ich mir denn anschauen für einen Link?
Der Typ unten im Thumbnail.
Der sieht ein bisschen schockiert aus, dass er in einem Video gelandet ist.
Was ist das?
Ok, Evoli, was ist das?
Was soll das sein?
Was gucke ich da? Evoli, was hast du mir da geschickt?
Was gucke ich da?
Was ist das denn?
Funktioniert nicht so ganz, oder?
Ok, was auch immer. Keine Ahnung.
Kannst du noch die Fragen aus dem Pepega Board beantworten? Ja, kann ich.
Monitorgeschichten hatten wir, Monitor hatten wir, Clip hatten wir, 144Hz hatten wir.
Haben wir überhaupt noch Fragen drinne?
Ist die Samsung S360 EVO für 100 Euro ein guter Deal?
Ich hab mir doch auch eine gekauft.
Ich hab mir doch auch jetzt letztens, ne, ich hab mir eine 970 EVO gekauft.
Wir kriegen jetzt eigentlich relativ 960 EVO.
Was, ne NVMe oder ne SSD?
Ne, 860 EVO.
Für 100 Euro, naja.
Achso.
Keine Ahnung, ob das ein guter Deal ist. Kriegen wir raus, was die anderen dafür haben wollen.
Ja, 100 Euro klingt ganz ok.
100 Euro klingt doch ganz ok.
Mittlerweile sind die Dinger echt billig geworden.
Ja, ich hab auch die 970. Ich hab übrigens noch hier jetzt liegen, eine 2TB SSD und eine 1TB SSD.
Das müssen wir auch mal machen demnächst, weil ich hab ja gesagt, ich will, ich brauche ein bisschen mehr Speicher.
Ok, ja. Also ich wollte eigentlich mal meinen Gaming Rechner hier neu installieren auf der 1TB NVMe SSD und dann noch die 2TB SATA SSD dran machen.
Also ich hab hier noch, ich hab ja eigentlich noch eine 6TB Magnetplatte dran. Die reicht mir eigentlich auch, deswegen hab ich mir überlegt, ich mach das ganz anders.
Ich mach die 1TB NVMe SSD rein hier in Desktop, lass die 6TB Platte dran für Speicher und mach die 2TB SSD in mein Nass rein.
Weil, dann flutscht das wenigstens ordentlich. Dann lohnt sich wenigstens mal, dass ich eine 10G Netzwerkkarte drinne hab.
Ok, was gab's sonst noch für Fragen?
Das hab ich schon beantwortet.
Ich hab auch, ich hab ganz viele Kisten mit alten Kabeln, die müsste ich echt mal wegschmeißen.
Weil kein Mensch braucht so viele Verlängerungskabel oder irgendwelche Klinkenkabel oder Olle, Olle für die, ich hab noch Kabel für die, für die Wii und sowas.
Ich hab noch nicht mal eine Wii, die überhaupt damit anschließen könnte.
IDE-Kabel, ja.
Nee, kenn ich nicht.
Ist der, ist der ZX eigentlich nur ein großer Switch oder macht der noch mehr?
Ach, du meinst den Dezix. Das ist im Prinzip ein ganz viel großer Switch, ja.
Kennste den Dolphin-Emo? Ja.
Aber ich hab schon lange nicht mal ausprobiert, wie gut das mittlerweile funktioniert.
Das soll ja mittlerweile ziemlich, ziemlich, ziemlich gut sein. Du kannst ja auch mit, kannst ja mittlerweile sogar Breath of the Wild ganz gut emulieren auf dem PC.
Ja, genau, ich könnte mir auch so einen Stuhl, so eine Heizung für einen Stuhl bauen.
Homepage von Stack Overflow hatten wir morgens schon nie gesehen, noch nie gesehen.
Was nutzt du eigentlich an Router? Musst mal meine Unity Media Shitbox tauschen.
Naja, das Problem ist, also das Ding, was ich an Router verwende, ist halt hinter der Unity Media Shitbox, weil mein Router ist halt ein Router und kein Kabelmodem.
Das heißt, man braucht die Unity Media Shitbox auf jeden Fall.
Mikrotik-Sellout.
Na, als Ersatz, als Ersatz für eine Unity Media Box bringt sich, lohnt sich halt die Mikrotik-Geschichte nicht.
Ich hab halt die Unity Media Box und Mikrotik dahinter.
Übrigens Leute, morgen ist es soweit. Morgen wird die Telekom abgeschaltet bei mir.
Und dann, ein paar Tage später, gibt's Upgrade Unity Media 40 MBit up, 400 down.
Und das ist, das ist aber schon von gestern die Frage.
Hab ich irgendwelche Fragen übersehen?
Hast du immer noch Dual-Stack-Line? Nein, hab ich nicht. Ich hab Unity Media lang genug genervt.
Lang genug genervt, dass mich dann irgendwann Samstags mal ein Techniker von Unity Media angerufen hat und gesagt hat, ich soll's mal ausprobieren, ob's jetzt funktioniert.
Und sie da, es hat funktioniert, es ist wieder IPv4.
Und der Support auf Twitter hat mir auch versichert, dass ich durch das Upgrade weiterhin IPv4 behalte.
Beziehungsweise, ähm, sie das sofort wieder umschalten, sollte es nicht passieren.
Können wir mal gucken, wie sehr das funktioniert, was Unity Media da so schreibt.
Kannst du nicht einfach ein Kabelmodem holen? Doch, doch, klar.
Aber ich find ein bisschen unsinnig, weil ich mein, man hat ja von Unity Media schon eins, warum sollte man auch eins holen?
Der einzige Unterschied ist halt, dass ich dann nur einen Modem hab und nicht noch quasi diesen verkappten Unity Media Router dazwischen.
Wollt mir für Backups eine USB 3 Docking Station für SATA Festplatten kaufen, schreibt ja omgitsmo.
Ähm, gibt aber...
Vielleicht soll ich mal das Emote wegmachen.
Wollt mir eine für SATA Festplatten...
Gibt aber nur welche von Billigfirmen mit relativ viel eine Sterne Reviews.
Kennst du da eine gute Alternative zur Docking Station?
Da gibt's doch, also ich hab von Chakun mal so ein Ding gekauft, das funktioniert seit Jahren schon ganz gut.
Ich hab so ein Ding von, das Ding hab ich mal gekauft vor Ewigkeiten und das funktioniert eigentlich ganz gut, aber es ist halt eine USB 3.
Das ist Billig China Ding?
Haha, Moonbeard Desmond.
Ja, ähm, das muss man echt übermachen.
Stream und stream, äh, dann Unity Media auf Flamestream und dann Unity Media auf Twitter vollspammen.
Aber, das, die Sache ist die, ähm, der Twittersupport von Unity Media gibt sich wirklich sehr viel Mühe.
Das ist die falschen, die es trifft, wenn man sie nervt.
Ja, was spricht denn gegen so eine hier?
Die scheint mir doch ganz okay zu sein.
Oh, da war eigentlich auch sowas hier, das sieht halt noch ein bisschen billiger aus.
Die haben halt viele einen Stern Bewertungen, die sagen, dass es ihnen Daten zerschossen hat.
Ja, wer weiß, was die Leute da immer treiben.
Also ich hatte bisher mit dem Sharkoon Ding noch keine Probleme.
Max geht, er ist noch nicht wach.
Also, sollten die mich auf DS Lite umstellen, werde ich sofort kündigen.
Und, ähm, dann gehe ich lieber wieder zur Telekom, weil DS Lite ist einfach Bullshit.
Wäre es ja mittlerweile so, dass alles ohne Probleme mit IPv6 gut funktioniert und man überall IPv6 Anbindungen hat
und auch auf dem Weg alles IPv6 ist, hey, dann wäre alles in Ordnung, da bräuchte ich auch keine IPv4 mehr, aber...
Ich gehe stark davon aus, dass wir nie vollständig IPv4 loswerden, nie.
Zumindest nicht zu unseren Lebzeiten.
Hatten wir schon?
Ja, das ist vom Stream gestern, da ging es um den Staubsauger, da muss ich jetzt nicht mehr viel erzählen.
Aber DS Lite macht normalerweise heute keine mehr, außer Unity Media.
Und wahrscheinlich Cable Deutschland und alle anderen, die zu wenig IPv4 Adressen haben.
Was ist denn der Vorteil von IPv6 außer größerem Adressraum?
Hauptsächlich der größere Adressraum.
Und dass ein paar Sachen ganz gut durchdacht sind.
Zum Beispiel die automatische Adressvergabe ist ganz gut durchdacht.
Man muss theoretisch, wenn du Rechner zusammenstöpst, gar keine IP-Adressen mehr vergeben.
Eigentlich brauchst du auch kein DHCP mehr.
Nutt gibt es auch nicht mehr.
Also doch, das stimmt nicht, Nutt gibt es theoretisch noch, aber macht mit der Anzahl der Adressen natürlich wenig Sinn.
Das war es glaube ich zum größten Teil.
Das Wichtigste ist auf jeden Fall, dass es mehr Adressen gibt.
Ich muss ehrlich sagen, so schön IPv6 ist, von dem was es bringt.
Ich glaube, dass IPv4 sich für interne Sachen doch recht lang halten wird.
Klar, es gibt DNS. Eigentlich ist DNS die Antwort darauf, dass man sich IP-Adressen nicht merken kann.
Und man kann IPv6-Adressen gekürzt schreiben.
Aber es ist trotzdem viel einfacher, sich IPv4-Adressen zu merken als IPv6-Adressen.
Allerdings, was auf jeden Fall sein wird, dass in Zukunft so ziemlich alles Dual-Stack hat.
Weil wenn man intern IPv4 hat, kann man natürlich nicht mit was externem kommunizieren, was IPv6 hat.
Und auch nicht mit großartigem, das einzige vielleicht, wenn du mit Proxy dazwischen hast oder so.
Aber zumindest nicht direkt.
Das bringt auch nichts, wenn ein Router da irgendwelche Magic macht.
Umgedreht funktioniert es. Umgedreht geht das.
Wenn du externe IPv6-Adresse hast und interne IPv4-Adresse, dann kannst du es mappen.
Aber umgedreht geht es nicht.
Weil von außen nach innen ist klar, da kannst du ganz fest diese IPv6-Adresse auf diese interne IPv4-Adresse mappen.
Das funktioniert. Umgedreht funktioniert das Ganze nicht.
Du kannst ja nicht deine IPv4 für die restliche Welt irgendwie mappen.
Also willst du IPv6 verwenden, IPv6 Internet verwenden, brauchst du selbst eine IPv6-Adresse.
Kann man eigentlich irgendwie sehen, wie viel Bandbreite andere Rechner gerade im Netz nutzen?
Wenn dein Router das kann, kannst du einfach gucken, was da über die Ports drüber geht oder an einem Switch.
Also du kannst nicht von deinem Rechner gucken, was andere Rechner gerade für Bandbreite verwenden.
Weil du siehst den Traffic von anderen Rechnern ja nicht.
Das ist ja gerade der Sinn von einem Switch.
Ja, Sharks Development, das geht.
Du kannst einen, na wobei so einfach ist das auch nicht.
So einfach ist das auch nicht. Eingehend geht das, ausgehend geht das nicht so ohne weiteres.
Du kannst zwar einen IPv4, einen IPv4 VPN aufbauen, dann brauchst du da drüber aber auch auf beiden Seiten eine IPv6-Adresse,
die du dann quasi über diesen Tunnel verpackt schickst.
Das ist dann quasi so ein bisschen sowas wie DualStack Lite.
Cisco oder HP-Switches, da geht das auf jeden Fall.
Da siehst du, was für Bandbreite verbraucht wird.
Also jeder halbwegs gescheite Router oder Switch, der ein bisschen besser ist,
der zum Beispiel auch entweder eine Management-Web-Interface hat oder Management-Kommandozeile hat,
hast du so einen Graph-Tab, wo man sieht, was da in Bandbreite verbraucht wird.
Was ist eigentlich dein Fazit zu Proxmox 6?
Ich fand das richtig gut. Also mir hat das echt gut gefallen.
Da haben sie sich ja nur mal kurz angeguckt im Stream und haben festgestellt,
dass sich Windows ME nicht richtig installieren lässt.
Ich fand es richtig gut.
Das Web-Interface hat mir, also für den Heimgebrauch, das Web-Interface hat mir gut gefallen.
Die Möglichkeiten, die man hat, hat man gut gefallen.
ZFS08 hat mir auch gut gefallen.
Mir hat das Rebooten gut gefallen.
Weißt du, ob es eine Fritzbox das kann?
Ich weiß es nicht, ob eine Fritzbox Bandbreite Nutzung anzeigen kann,
aber ich würde mal drauf tippen, dass sie das kann.
Ich habe mir das noch nie angeguckt auf einer Fritzbox,
aber ich würde sagen, man kann sich auch bei einer Fritzbox bestimmt angucken,
was die anderen Leute im Netzwerk für eine Bandbreite brauchen.
Eine Fritzbox kann das nicht? Echt nicht? Okay.
Meinst du, dass es sich lohnt, von Proxmox 5 auf 6 zu gehen?
Kann ich nichts zu sagen, weil ich, wie gesagt, schon ewig keinen Proxmox mehr verwendet habe
und einfach mal Testinitialisationen mit dem Sechser gemacht habe.
So Leute, ich glaube, wir sind wach.
2,5 Stunden gestreamt heute Morgen.
Also ich bin zumindest wach, auch wenn ich gerade gegent habe.
Ich werde jetzt mal gucken.
Wird ja schon fast Zeit, dass ich mir überlege, was ich für heute Mittagessen mache.
Irgendjemand Honest, der man hosten kann?
Livestream C++.
Cute Stream.
3D Trocken ist immer noch on.
Die Tüte hat die ganze Zeit.
Leute, ich gehe jetzt auf. Vielleicht bin ich nachher noch mal on.
Mal gucken, wenn wir ein bisschen Technik-Grams machen nachher noch.
Ich weiß bloß nicht genau, wann und was.
Also falls mir was Gutes einfällt heute Mittag für ein Stream,
dann machen wir noch mal ein Stream und wir sehen uns bis denn.
Macht's gut.